[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello I/O
Live, Todd Kerpelman here.
And I am here with Jonathan
Hui, who is a principal software
engineer over at Nest.
Hi, Jonathan.
JONATHAN HUI: Hi.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what is this
that we've got behind us here,
this OpenThread stuff?
What is that all about?
JONATHAN HUI: Yeah, so
Thread is an open IP
based mesh networking protocol
for low power connected
IoT devices.
OpenThread is an open source
implementation of that protocol
and it's available at GitHub.
It's an open development model.
Everybody can
contribute, anybody
in the public, not just Nest.
So what we're showing
here is a bunch
of devices, 10
different platforms,
running OpenThread, operating
in a single IPv6 mesh network
all communicating together.
We have a Raspberry
Pi in the corner that
connects this to a Wi-Fi network
and communicates via the cloud.
All of these devices
are communicating
their topology information
within that mesh to the cloud.
And we display that
on this display
here so you can see
a full connected mesh
network with the devices here.
What we're showing here
is a Thread sniffer.
So this is a standard Wireshark
capturing all the traffic
operating in this
mesh network that is
used to maintain this topology.
TODD KERPELMAN: So if
I were a developer that
were looking to make a device
that worked in a smart home,
I could basically take any
of these microprocessors
here and use
OpenThread as my way
to make sure that my device
hooks up with everything
else in the home.
JONATHAN HUI: That's
exactly right.
As I mentioned, OpenThread now
supports 10 different radios.
And in fact, many of
the silicon vendors
actually provide direct
customer support of OpenThread
on their radios.
So I would encourage
you, if you're already
working with a favorite
silicon vendor of yours,
to reach out directly
to that silicon vendor
and ask about OpenThread.
TODD KERPELMAN:
And what are some
of the what are some of the
cool features about OpenThread?
What makes it sort of an
interesting networking
protocol?
JONATHAN HUI: The
first is that it really
supports IP, which means
it's the same technology that
is used to connect any other
internet connected device.
And that makes it
really convenient.
For example, when
you're developing
using standard Linux, you
can use standard sockets APIs
to communicate
with your devices.
But more importantly,
because you're using IP,
it means you can build solutions
that utilize multiple link
technologies such as
Wi-Fi, cellular, and Thread
with a single application
layer communicating end to end.
You do not have to have
application gateways
in between, which
often represent
a single point of failure.
And with Thread, because
there's no stateful application
gateways, you can have
multiple connections
into and out of the network.
That makes it really
resilient to have
no single point of failure.
TODD KERPELMAN:
That is very cool.
And I notice there's this
QR code here behind me.
What does that do?
JONATHAN HUI: Yeah,
so Thread by default
requires you to have security
enabled, which is actually
one of the key differentiators.
And because security
is always enabled,
you need to have a very
user friendly process
of getting that device
securely onto the network.
And so what the QR code does
is it enables a mobile app.
You just turn it on,
you scan the QR code,
and it will securely connect
with that joining device
to provide the security
credentials to get
that device onto the network.
TODD KERPELMAN: I think
I've used that when I've
set up my own Nest devices.
It makes things
super convenient.
JONATHAN HUI: Exactly.
It's very similar to
what we do at Nest.
In fact, the
commissioning protocol
was designed following the
principles that we use at Nest.
And so it really does enable
a great user experience.
TODD KERPELMAN: Very nice.
And so what is Nest
doing with OpenThread?
JONATHAN HUI: Yeah, so
if we move over here,
Nest is actually
enabling a number
of products with OpenThread.
The first is a connected
deadbolt for your door.
It only communicates via Thread.
It's got no other kind
of technology with it.
And because it's using
Thread, it can actually
last for years on AA batteries.
And I can do a quick demo here.
So if I open up my mobile
app, hold down the button,
we'll see the door
unlock and there it goes.
And that's all
happening over Thread.
Of course, the mobile is
communicating over Wi-Fi.
It goes to a Thread
border router
to this battery powered device.
TODD KERPELMAN: Would that
work if my phone were not
connected to the Wi-Fi?
JONATHAN HUI: It would work.
So as I mentioned,
our application layer
operates over any IPv6 network.
So it just happens that this
mobile phone is only on Wi-Fi.
But you know, if it was
connected to cellular
that would work as well.
TODD KERPELMAN: Very cool.
That is very interesting.
And if I were a developer and I
were interested in finding out
more about OpenThread to use in
my products, where would I go?
JONATHAN HUI: Yeah, so we have
a website at OpenThread.io.
We have our source code
at GitHub.com/OpenThread.
And you can reach us at Google
Groups at OpenThread-users.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So if you're interested in
making your own cool internet
connected device
that, I don't know,
does something amazing that
I haven't thought of yet,
go head on over to OpenThread.io
and check it out for yourself.
Thank you very much, Jonathan.
JONATHAN HUI: Thank
you very much.
TODD KERPELMAN: Bye, y'all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]